I love Halloween almost as much as I
love wearing tights it's the only day of
the year when everyone's allowed to
dress up the way they normally would if
society didn't have so many hang-ups
about people and hockey masks with blood
all over them it's the day when you can
leave all the entrails and cobwebs in
your house and just tell everyone
they're decorations but on this recent
Halloween in particular I felt like
testing an age-old bit of controversy in
the comics that has never had a
definitive answer
how did spider-man make such a kick-ass
costume when he's poor and has no sewing
experience most teenage boys I know
aren't that great at sewing so he must
have had a difficult time putting it
together the adaptations ever since have
always kind of glossed over it one way
or another the Sam Raimi movies show him
drawing it and then he just has it one
day and it looks like $100,000 rubber
suit with no visible seams then Andrew
Garfield made his buy of something to do
with silk-screening and sunglasses
they'll really cover the gritty details
either although I do like how his suit
looks kind of unfinished messy then he
too just wakes up one day and here's the
perfect one Tom Hollands spider-man just
had a billionaire throw it together in
an afternoon and he didn't do any of the
work on it even in the Ultimate Comics
it's a professional suit made by a
Wrestling Federation and he just draw
some lines on it I guess what we can
gather from these examples is that him
making himself is kind of unrealistic
and they either just say he did all the
hard part's off-screen or he had someone
else do it well let's test that with
less than $100 and some junk I found at
a Halloween store a few weeks back I'll
build my own suit I have about as much
sewing skill just as limited resources
as Peter Parker and we're about the same
age so why not give it a shot I think
using the comics as a sort of blueprint
for all the pieces we could build
something pretty cool the first step is
gathering materials the spider-man
ultimate guide has an entry about Peter
hearing that his schools dance team was
throwing away a bunch of spandex body
suits
so naturally he does his dumpster diving
routine and finds one that fits and
grabs a couple of extra ones for
additional material to cut up that means
he didn't have to take all the annoying
measurements for every square inch of
his body and then cut a log of fabric to
fit a pattern
he had a suit though is his size and he
just attached a bunch of extra parts to
it like any lazy ass teenager would
perfect I'll find something similar
during October I worked at a local
Halloween store that's only open
seasonally and I found a bunch of lycra
bodysuits near the back of the store
that were just not getting sold so I
bought them myself with the intention of
slicing them up with scissors close
enough and I also found these cat
goggles in there with reflective plastic
lenses sure these were probably meant
for like a Catwoman costume but they'll
suit my needs I figure Aunt May has a
sewing machine and various equipment
lying around the house since she is an
old lady and we all know every woman
over the age of 50 owns a vast amount of
sewing supplies now the fun part
attaching plastic disband X without
ruining either of them well I could just
wear the goggles over the mask like a
chump but we can do better than that
that means I'll grab a dremel tool and
hack this thing in a shape the mask will
both be lighter and fit better with
these pieces segmented and attached on
their own I practice this with a pair of
spider-man sunglasses in a store-bought
costume for comic-con or later this year
I have to be really careful not to make
a stray mark that scratches the lenses
for safety I put cloth over the shiny
part it's also way easier to see through
this than white spandex I think it's a
little dumb how they always half-ass
drawing it just make the eyes solid
white and then the movies try to make it
solid white too if they're polarized
lenses how the hell does he see with
them at night whatever anyway after you
snap the glasses into a million pieces
and cover yourself in black dust you
drill a series of small holes in it to
thread a needle through
after that apply the secret to any good
superhero costume glue fabric glue to
keep the edges from fraying and liquid
stitch to attach the plastic then you
put the stitches in after the glue
hardens that way you have a backup if
the glue gives out and you have a backup
of the stitches snap which is liable to
happen in this line of work man this is
a pain in the ass make sure you look up
the basics of stitching before you do
this not super complicated or hard to
learn lots of different kinds of not see
out to tie to make it look neat after
you jab yourself in the finger with a
needle a dozen times you have yourself a
mask following that step I put on the
red suit and made the marks for where
the lines will be when I cut it which
basically meant I just sat there drawing
on myself with a sharpie that bled
through to my skin anyway
I imagine he probably did the smarter
thing and took the spandex bodysuit and
folded it in half so his lines were
symmetrical but he also didn't have to
make a video tutorial well now comes the
scary part can't exactly get a do-over
on this just duh just be careful okay
make sure the lines are drawn a little
bigger than what you'll actually use
because you need to fold it over and
smooth out the edges this is a process
called hemming it's so the stupid thing
doesn't fall apart and unravel in about
two seconds from all the strings hanging
out of it make sure to buy a lot of this
stuff because you should put it on every
single edge to be safe make sure you cut
around the zipper on the red suit
because the blue suit is the one where
the zipper will remain mostly intact
after I got the red piece all cut out
and ready I needed to tend to the blue
bodysuit a bit basically I have to slice
off the hands feet and mask and then hem
up the line to make sure the zipper is
still usable after slicing it in half
with absurdly sharp scissors keep the
thingy below the neck of the suit and
then create a makeshift stopper for it
by stitching around the zipper a few
dozen times
it's janky but it works next getting
precise measurements and putting the
pins into it isn't exactly something I
can give you advice for it's just hard
to do when you'll wish you had an extra
set of hands to do it
stringing up a sewing machine is
something you can either learn through
trial and error or just ask really vague
leading questions to Aunt May just tell
her you want to make your own sweater
vests from now on and you need to learn
these kinds of things as you grow up
hemming lines is super easy if you're
competent know what you're doing as you
can tell by how straight that stitch is
I'm not competent or know what I'm doing
the worst thing about a secret identity
is you can't ask someone else to do your
sewing now after snipping the blue suit
down to fit what we need you can start
erratically doing whatever you feel like
in no particular pattern to put off
using the sewing machine and hurting
your pride anymore
so let's draw on some lines first step
is to go into the appropriately themed
lavatory and put the mask on so it's
stretched out properly on your head then
instead of silk-screening it just get
lazy and draw the lines on with a marker
what could go wrong after washing the
lines off of your face and pushing out
of that like a huge coward find a
mannequin to put the mask on as soon as
you come to the realization that you
don't have a mannequin it's important to
follow these steps to the letter 1 find
an old unrelated Halloween mask in your
closet to stuff it full of hand towels
until it resembles the size and shape of
the human skull then awkwardly draw the
webs on over the course of two days got
all that perfect in all seriousness I do
recommend using an action figure or
multiple pictures for visual reference
try to really study how the webs curve
and how they differ from one drawing to
the next alright enough stalling get the
red piece cut out the right way and put
it over the blue suit take the three
hours necessary to pin every piece of
the blue suit to the red try doing this
in your living room while a good TV show
plays in the background so you don't get
bored oh and an additional step is to
get one of the needles the puncture
cleaned through your arm in two places
and bleed a little on the suit authentic
Battle Damage I call it Jesus this is a
train wreck what am I even doing take
the suit off very carefully so the pins
stay in and make sure you don't stab
yourself and your delicate nether
regions while working on it future
spider women out there will find this
somewhat less stressful than Spider Men
guys wear a cup don't be like Andrew
over there now so until your fingers
hurt
[Music]
if you want to look neat and hey
yourself
flip it inside out and have all the
threads on the inside of suit if you
want to save your sanity so the outside
of the suit so you can see what the hell
you're doing if you use the right color
thread no one will be able to see the
stitches anyway who cares
okay got all that shoplifts some of
these snap buttons from your local
Walmart and sew them onto the gloves and
the main suit so you don't have to worry
about the pieces detaching then do some
more drawings the web pattern is fun
because you can use inspiration from a
lot of sources on how it should look the
spider on the chest is also where you
can sort of customize it's been drawn a
million different ways by a million
different people I just used the logo
from one of my t-shirts for reference
since I like that one and had the
classic feel to it if you want a giant
pointy one that covers your whole chest
go for it the spider on the back is the
same deal but you have to cut it I have
some spare fabric since the leg pieces
of the red suit were still lying around
I printed off a stencil and cut it out
of that on top of a piece of foam I
pinned it to I am shocked by how well it
came out on my first try as always put
the seal and glue on the edges of
everything to make sure it doesn't fall
apart later after it settles slice it up
the middle so there's room for the
zipper and then glue the inside I kept a
full mat inside the suit in case it bled
through then up well up I guess it's
just done huh that was long and annoying
I didn't put the opening in the middle
by choice but I guess you could do that
if you want then add some buttons so it
snaps the two pieces together I'm kind
of surprised this was so doable I get
why he complains so much about replacing
these though making one of these suits
takes a while and doesn't allow you a
ton of free time but boy does it feel
cool to have it done Peter Parker had
the time and money to make web fluid in
high school he could probably do this
with more ease than I did
yes Peter Parker could absolutely make
his costume
would it look like $100,000 Hollywood
masterpiece sculpted by a team of
costume department experts nope it would
look more like this something charming
about the simplicity of it and now that
I've given you these hectic and
disorganized instructions you too can
live out childhood fantasies of running
across rooftops and getting stabbed by
muggers and dirty inner-city alleyways
or you can just make some cool cosplay
to wear while you go to comic book
conventions you giant nerd now if only I
knew how to make industrial-strength
glue that expands into rubber on contact
with oxygen I guess that'll be a later
video
[Music]